[Applause]
the security forces were always going to
break up the anti-government
demonstrations in Caracas it wasn't a
matter of if but when they started to
move in but a crowd weren't cowed and
they fought back
they dragged anything they could to
protect themselves from rubber bullets
clouds of tear gas filled the air as
volley off the body were fired into the
protesters well right the minute I
started we sort of expected it because
teargas been fired into the air they're
dragging anything they can find on the
streets to create barricades to smash it
up the road out getting their weapon to
throw at the National Guard it around
the corner from here
we've been teargas five these people
have had enough I think it was
inevitable that this would happen but
this is going to get violently already
is between people being killed and this
is going to be chaotic it's very
difficult to see now consider over
teargas and after a peaceful rally
that's it's now descended into street
fighting
the crowd swayed backwards and forwards
as the police reposition themselves
making charges towards the protesters
causing their stampedes amongst the
thousands attempting to hold their
ground but trying to escape the choking
gas fires were started in the middle of
the city streets scaffolding and
signposts ripped down to use as weapons
brandishing some of the missiles fired
at the protesters this young man says
he's fighting for his gun hand than the
police charge again it was always going
to be like this president Maduro is
under pressure but with the military and
police still on board he hasn't the
formidable power but there is people
power as well and they defied government
intimidation to take to the streets in
numbers unseen here for years
from all over Caracas they came in there
hundreds of thousands the streets of the
city's downtown filled with throngs of
people jubilant that after waiting for
months even years to gather again like
this they finally had then unexpectedly
they heard that the opposition leader
when Guido had for the first time openly
declared himself interim president and
then he appeared sending the crowd into
ecstasy the 35 year olds leadership of
the opposition to the country's nominal
leader Nicolas Maduro has galvanized the
people of Venezuela he has the common
touch stopping to help a lady who had
fallen over picking her up and giving
her her kiss on the cheeks she seemed
almost overwhelmed there's now two
presidents
yeah grunting yeah because you know what
I'm talking about
Naruto because Naruto it's not a really
Priscilla for our country it's a
dictator yeah now we are trying to
change the situation in our country
because we have services we don't have
food we don't have freedom if you don't
have freedom with over humanity help
Cueto's team insist he's the legitimate
leader despite widespread international
support for the opposition takeover a
backlash seems inevitable they're
building barricades on the streets again
they won't hold them for sure now the
opposition holds the momentum for change
here is just as tenuous Aransas can use
correct